[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
you're not happy with what you are I'm
happy with what you are there's some of
these girls man sometimes you piss me
off but so these girls know they're like
you know they think that I'm like the
devil or something man
they're feeling like a [ __ ] coochie
Destroyer man I'm not a coochie
Destroyer I don't think you've ever been
unable to cook yeah do they call you you
know you know coochie killer and could
you destroy two different things
whatever coochie killer
yeah the Beast of the night you know
Gucci killer dry up you dry them out
they call you desert man you come around
and they just
[Laughter]
that's what I see dude you don't think
that it's over for me no no no no no no
no you're just getting started yeah so
what do I do do I do Tinder no no not
only from Tinder no why not it's Rogue
as [ __ ] out there on Tinder don't go to
Tinder you're gonna get monkey pox on
Tinder yeah you gotta go Raya monkey pox
go on Ryan go on Raya I don't want to do
Ryan I'm on Raya right check this Ryan
yeah you want right yeah that's for the
no I'm not good looking enough they lit
they sent me a thing and said not hot
enough not enough credit so my Riot
right it's like this person this person
is a snowboarder from Australia that's
where she lives
[Music]
this one's from why don't you change
terrorists Paris France that's not real
that's not happening Bobby we're not
getting here I know you know no they do
some this girl right here talks to me we
did a conversation but I guess where she
lives
she's lives in Papale city Taiwan but
why you have to set the distance they
don't do that they don't do that it's
the worst app ever it really is so I'm
getting hot chicks from all over the
world but I'm not gonna [ __ ] go there
it's like
she she lures me in with
sexy DMS you know what I mean it's not a
badge not brass but look silhouettes of
her body this and that right and this
goes on for a long time brah you know so
I reciprocate or no reciprocated
reciprocate means you sent her something
back yeah but like funny photos I mean
like a silhouette and how to do this
yeah with those ones did you know her or
was it just I didn't know her oh and you
sent her a picture back yeah and then
then
I don't want to tell you where but I fly
to go see her right this country
yeah okay
you think I flew to [ __ ] Moscow
no okay as far as you'd think
it's just halfway around the world yeah
yeah pretty far
it's farthest point of yeah yeah it's
far yeah
right and then I um
you know we I go there and she I go
there to hook up but like she just
leaves right away we have a date we make
out a little bit she leaves and I make
all these plans to see her this and that
and then all of a sudden she's writes me
this thing like I'm done I don't want to
see you anymore but you're the one that
[ __ ] sent the thing so she got what
she needed though what a kiss from booby
Lee yeah yeah but my point is is that
you know so and I I feel like I'm at a
point where I'm like
yeah it's not I know I think I'm done it
makes me feel unwanted and ugly well you
put yourself out there it didn't work
the first time you got to keep trying
dating's hard
that's what it is yeah I think you want
it to be a lot faster but just take your
time no I mean I'm seeing this other
girl in L.A
right now that just leave me out no but
it's a Cry Me a River you're like this
one girl I flew to you yeah and there's
40 other women I'm talking to right now
but
here's what so many women are on the on
the on your dossier right now I planted
about 30 seats oh my God I don't want
fancy
who Reba I know I understand I don't
want fancy puss I understand what you're
saying you have like a Down to Earth I
want a combination between plumber and
fancy and hinge hinge what's hinge hinge
hinges of Tinder and Raya had a baby
really yeah hinge is where I yeah I've
had relationships like started
relationships right yeah
so uh let's start with this lady she
goes um
I opened up with mysterious you are
right and she goes well I know you were
little you're very funny
then I do these two things yeah no
response yeah what do you mean yeah they
they have
50 guys they're juggling right now we
just don't stand out we're average we're
average looking people these people work
at Target doesn't matter
you know I mean they're getting hit on
by like good looking guys good even
though it's a good looking guys they
don't discriminate they all be hard
you're you're the hottest I've ever seen
or whatever they just so you're
basically what you're saying is I'm
[ __ ] yes we're both [ __ ] yes I am I
think you should [ __ ] I think you should
just write to them you should the first
message hi is ornie Adams your favorite
comedian too
question mark
we can't have you on Tinder no you can't
you got to be on you at least got to be
on people wouldn't even I'm on Tinder
I'm getting off you should not be Tinder
I met this how I met kalila my
girlfriend
that was different nine years ago yeah
it's a different time no right it's just
all so you're saying that I'll there's
they're all they all look like Shrek
yeah cause when I I when I got Tinder
again I still have it on my phone it's
horrible it's horrible
losers losers this is my Tinder okay
okay these are my masks what are you
doing better on Tinder Bumble or hinge
and also there is somebody exposing you
for lying about your age on tick tock
why you're the most honest person I know
besides the story in South Africa
actually you're not you lie all the time
on your podcast I see people calling you
out why do you lie about your age we all
know you're 42. I know because
I'm 51. okay okay and the reason why is
because when I first got the apps I was
honest about my age but I was matching
with people that were in their 50s and I
wanted to see what it would be like
because I play Young you know I test
young and so I was like well how do I
get you know I mean
25 year olds that are fans of mine right
to see my profile and I figured if I lie
about my age because they already know
who I am so I already know that I am 51
if you're because I feel like no one's
going to want to go on a date with me
well then put in the Pro because some
people do that really 51 not 39. oh my
thing you can put that in the
description maybe I'll do that yeah you
think I should do that yeah I do it's so
funny because not that I'm attracted to
anybody but in the last three months
I've been like helping female Comics out
more right like doing their podcast not
because I'm attracted to them or I want
to have sex with them or anything like
that yeah it's just that I'm kind of
opening my doors back up to just women
in general do I describe my penis or no
no okay let them be
is to be in Surprise yeah they're always
surprised at my penis surprised and
delighted what it's cute it's cute yeah
yeah it's like a minion it's cute
it's yellow it's got little eyes it's
great it's got glasses
yeah but um
don't bring it up don't bring it up
right yeah no and then let me ask you
in the third day do you wear a condom
yeah yeah
unless you're trying to get one of them
knocked up yeah whoever you want to get
Knocked Up don't wear a condom with that
person
oh I see you want the ladies to know
that Bobby's open for business yeah I
mean I'm not like you know a [ __ ] right
um you know I I'm dabbling around you
know it's good
um good for you but I'm dabbling around
um I'm a little picky okay as you should
be I think I should be sure but
um you know um I like personalities as
well you know what I mean but you know I
like beautiful faces you know I like
your New Yorker like some of you New
Yorkers I like you the girls have
beautiful faces but their hands are like
coal miner yeah yeah right and they have
a voice like hey how you doing you know
whatever I don't know what to do in New
York but you know what I mean
okay what do you mean duly noted can I
compliment you go ahead your [ __ ]
strawberry kisses nails are looking so
cute thank you yeah those are that color
is it's getting me a little horny I'm
not lying are you being real it's a sexy
color thank you and I usually Reserve
that for like if when I see it on you
know well single Bob wants to because
you know everyone says that my fingers
are like Wolverine pants yes they are
right yes they are and I wanted to
change that because I'm like dating now
can we get a manicure together we're
gonna get an excellent dude every other
week you want to get one no it's so fun
you want to go yes what color you want I
don't care yeah I got these ones
recently I was getting my oil changed I
went and got manicure yeah I want to see
like Bobby do they always have to be
Vietnamese yeah okay I'm gonna work out
that's what you're saying well I don't
look good I don't know but what if Bobby
might be a little weird though
but I've never tried buff body yeah
that'd be interesting yeah buff Bobby I
don't know how the people are gonna feel
about that if I was ripped they might
hate you more
but I'm gonna get the surgery
you know I want to get implants aware
facial implants because the face has to
match the buff body so I'm gonna get a
buff body shave my head yeah facial
implants yeah so it kind of looks like
it looked like a Korean insurrectionist
I had a date with a girl tonight and
this is the third time that she's
canceled on me oh I'm good at this hold
on so she goes let me hear it can we
reschedule dinner I woke up severely
depressed and I just can't shake it it
happens comes and goes I'm sorry I just
need to feel this which is fine I said
it's okay this is the second time I
think that's happened right and the
other time she was like do you think
it's the thought of going out on a date
with you is just depressing
I always recommend a FaceTime before the
date like just to make sure they look
like their pictures and we're busy
people we don't need to waste our time
showing up and the person doesn't look
so just be like hey when how could they
not look like the pitcher because people
people are catfishes yeah people don't
so if I show up at a coffee shop right
and and she's let's say I there's a girl
that's five eight belonging to me she
shows up she's 5'3 with the biggest
schnoz you've ever seen Bobby Ruth
that's false advertising yeah all right
do you leave everyone wants Love Bob oh
yeah you do oh yeah did you say
something you say yeah that's false
advertising
yeah I'll go home and kill myself yeah
you better get a lawyer
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] on Tinder so
basically these are all my matches
I always open why do first of number one
why do I have to open every conversation
that's just the way it is right every
conversation I open hi
um smiley emoji smiley no one responds
to me well because you don't quite smile
you hey how you like you have to look
into their profile and oh they like
volleyball hey have you played any good
volleyball games like you have to show
something because this lady likes to
bull ride so that's what she looks like
so I see her face I don't want to do
that but I seriously want to learn how
to bull ride
and I really do want to learn yeah but
she never responded to that that a lot
of those are fakes a lot of them are
fake so what what I learned yeah is not
to do Tinder yeah yeah yeah right and to
do uh maybe hinge hinge and Raya yes
yeah eventually eventually yeah yeah
yeah so I'm single now and um
I'm 50. you're 50. yeah you don't look
50.
and um damn oh I'm 50 years old okay and
I I feel like this this next phase in my
life
is a new adventure
and I don't know what it's going to
bring me but I'm very excited about you
are excited yeah I built this reputation
for myself you can ask people I don't
call people back
I don't text people back I'm kind of
hard to get a hold of real Hollywood I
like that no it's not Hollywood it's
just my way makes me feel better because
you called me pretty cool no I know well
no because you're you've caught me in a
transition yeah okay you've caught me in
a transition where um it's like those
wedding invitations out folks yeah I'm
trying to do this exactly yes Bobby's
got 30 million in them different you
know I'm trying to do everything it's
very good yeah yeah I'm I text everyone
back I um I show up to things that have
you know because usually you know I used
to be like I'm not doing it whatever if
it's a stand-up gig or if it's like a
job or you know an audition I'll show up
to those but if it's like a personal
thing and if you know I'm just like a
social thing yeah yeah I get it and it's
out of fear it's not because I don't
want to be intimate with people and this
and that but I'm like do last year or
two I've been kind of like going against
you know I mean
and it's been working it's working
that's right well we appreciate you
coming we appreciate it yeah thanks man
do you like sloppy joes
I do
[Music]